okay Fred you ready cool I'll take that
as a yes this is Fred Newman hey what do
you do Fred i honk for a living ha ha I
worked on the Nickelodeon show called
dog I did the sound design and music
dududududu distance dude that wasn't
Doug's voice that was actually my voice
just dude as good as boot we wanted to
use as much as we could household
objects things our kid with have make it
sound innocent because this is a kid's
diary I tended to do a lot of things
with my mouth dear journal and
everything so broke you had to catch him
your painting skills not only did Fred
work on the sounds of music but was also
avoids for a bunch of the character
porkchop dog he was actually kind of
talk but not quite wrong Skeeter it's
short for mosquito cool bad you know he
had the little hump hey Doug how you
doing man I saw here big nose
I just thought if you would always have
this sort of add noise thing going on a
lot of post nasal drip bud be welcome
newcomer
Ted big get with Keith and his name was
dink because of double income no kids
the beat
I need more allow us yodel a killer tofu
and that was kind of based on staying a
little bit while Doug maybe Fred's claim
to fame in our eyes he does all kinds of
sounds for movies TV and radio his first
movie was gremlin I came in did the bad
guy stripe oh wow
some of them are cute well I'm a sloth I
hope you a la lalala I did the sound
when the mobile I turned into the bad
guys
but Reds often on screen when you don't
even realize it
I get a lot of dogs I will go you gotta
put real human emotions coming out of
animals or doors the door has to sound
sad that's where I get called in okay
let's try a couple horse weasel ah a
lien Wow bird vibration the message I
say is whatever makes you weird go there
and pursue that - sound and never
thought the second I can do that for a
living yeah Here I am as a son seen
slowly in the West who did you all a
fond farewell
[Music]